you cannot wish for both strong
character and an easy life because the
price of one is the other if you're
going through hard times then it means
that you're paying the price to have the
character you ultimately want and if you
have an easier life then oftentimes we
sacrifice the hard-built character and
since most of us probably would identify
as having a harder life or the things
that we're willing to endure then I
think it's just simply asking ourselves
did we ultimately want to be the types
of people who could endure this thing
and if so then we are just walking the
journey that will give us the evidence
that we are who we say we are